[Musique]
créée en 2010 neuf sous l'impulsion du
conseil départemental de la réunion la
spl eden a mis en avant sa mission de
lutte anti-vectorielle dans toute l'île
au profit des personnes les plus
vulnérables
nous avons beaucoup de gens qui sont
atteints
et fait un travail qui doit se faire
c'est la compétence de l'état gourmet le
département il a à charge des personnes
âgées
64 c'est un seul mât ne sont plus en
capacité pendant le voit ici de pouvoir
entretenir leurs fours et du tout il y a
de plus en plus de moustiques et c'est
notre rôle
nous a été confiée par nos actionnaires
par un vote du parlement de venir sur
l'éligibilité des candidats venir les
accompagner et perd ensemble que l'on
puisse leur redonner un environnement
plus approprié pour une meilleure santé
la structure a remporté l'édition 2021
des trophées des ep hell entreprises
publiques locales dans la catégorie
service au public c'est patrick jarry
conseiller départemental des
hauts-de-seine et maire de nanterre en
visite à la réunion qui a remis le
trophée en sa qualité de président de la
fédération nationale des entreprises
publiques locales le jury a été sensible
à une
création assez inédite puisque pour la
première fois une une une spl est créé
dans le domaine de l'action sur pour la
santé et en même temps sur sur
l'insertion et le développement
écologique donc ça c'est c'est unique en
france
et donc on pense que peut-être donc ça
intéressait beaucoup le jury et
forcément ça a été ré c'est aussi
beaucoup la fédération de voir que
dans un territoire comme ici à la
réunion ont fait preuve de beaucoup de
créativité pour essayer de répondre à
des questions qui se posent aux
habitants et aux territoires autre
événement qui a marqué la première
journée de patrick jarry à la réunion la
signature d'une charte d'engagement de
la fédération des ep l est du
département dans la mise en oeuvre du
plan un million d'arbres précédée de la
plantation de trois espèces endémiques
dans la cour du palais de la source je
pense que le président cyrille melchior
et fiers aujourd'hui de pouvoir associer
l'ensemble des établissements publics
locaux de la réunion 37 établissements à
à ce programme à ce projet ambitieux le
plan un million d'arbres à la réunion
puisque dans ces établissements nous
avons des bailleurs sociaux nous avons
des structures d'aidé des sociétés
publiques locales d'aménagement qui
peuvent aussi apporter et contribuer à
la replantation de ces arbres endémiques
de ces espèces dans nos différents
territoires et signé avec le président
de la fédération des epn était un acte
fort mais signe fort qui montre
l'engagement de ces structures des
structures qui il faut le rappeler ce
sont aussi des structures qui sont au
service de la population comme le sont
les collectivités et il était tout à
fait normal et naturel qu'on puisse les
avoir comme partenaire de ce plan un
million d'arbres
[Musique]